A SEXUAL ENCOUNTER WITH
MR. TRUMP IN 2006 AND WAS PAID
AS PART OF A NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENT.
SHE IS SEEKING TO INVALIDATE IT.
THE WHITE HOUSE AND SENDING
MIXED SIGNALS TONIGHT AS EPA
ADMINISTRATOR SCOTT PRUITT IS
FACING NEW OBSTACLES IN HIS
EFFORT TO KEEP HIS JOB.
THE AGENCY LAWYER WHO ORIGINALLY
APPROVED PRUETT'S SWEETHEART
CONDO DEAL WITH THE LANDLORD
WENT TO A LOBBYIST NOW SAYS HE
DID NOT HAVE ALL THE FACTS.
CHIEF NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
ED HENRY, WHO TALKED EXCLUSIVELY
WITH PRUITT YESTERDAY, HAS
TONIGHT UPDATE.
>> ASKED TODAY IF HE STILL HAS
CONFIDENCE IN SCOTT PRUITT, HIS
EMBATTLED ADMINISTRATOR OF THE
EPA, PRESIDENT TRUMP SUGGESTED
HE DOES.
>> I THINK THAT SCOTT HAS DONE A
FANTASTIC JOB.
I THINK HE'S A FANTASTIC PERSON.
>> >> WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS
PRIVATELY NOTE THIS PRESIDENT
HAS PREVIOUSLY VOICED SUPPORT
FOR OTHER CABINET CHIEFS ONLY TO
PUSH THEM OUT FOR YOU CNN IS
REPORTING THE PRESIDENT SAW.
WITH INTERVIEW WITH FOX AND IS
NOT HAPPY.
>> IS DRAINING THE SWAP RENTING
AN APARTMENT FROM THE WIFE OF
WASHINGTON LOBBYIST?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT IS EVEN
REMOTELY FAIR TO ASK THAT
QUESTION.
>> WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS HAVE
SPREAD WHERE THEY TOLD PRUITT
NOT TO DO THE INTERVIEW BUT HE
FORGED AHEAD ANYWAY.
"CBS NEWS" IS REPORTING THAT
PRUITT WANTED TO USE SIRENS ON
HIS OFFICIAL CAR TO GET THEIR
WASHINGTON TRAFFIC AND WHEN A
MEMBER OF A SECURITY DETAIL SAID
IT WAS AGAINST THE RULES, THAT
PERSON WAS REASSIGNED.
WHILE A NEW MEMO FROM AN EPA
ETHICS LAWYER SUGGESTS HE ONLY
OKAYED TO THE APARTMENT
ARRANGEMENT BASED ON FEDERAL
GIFT RULES, BUT DID NOT HAVE ALL
THE FACTS TO DETERMINE WHETHER
IT PRESENTED A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
AS "THE DAILY BEAST" REPORTED,
THE LOBBYIST WHO RENTED THE
APARTMENT TO PRUITT HAD
REPRESENTED A COMPANY INVOLVED
IN A $104 MILLION SUPERFUND
CLEANUP LITIGATION AGAINST THE
EPA.
>> I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE FUTURE
OF SCOTT PRUITT COME I CAN JUST
TALK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE NOW.
>> IN ADDITION TO THE SOFT
WHITE HOUSE REPUBLICAN CALLED ON
HIM TO GO.
"THE UPSTATE NEW YORK LAWMAKER
BELIEVES "IT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE EPA FOR
MR. PRUITT TO RESIGN."
THOUGH SUPPORTERS OF PRUITT ARE
RALLYING TO HIS DEFENSE.
SENATOR RAND PAUL TWEETING,
"SCOTT PRUITT IS LIKELY THE
BRAVEST AND MOST CONSERVATIVE
MEMBER OF TRUMP'S CABINETS.
WE NEED HIM TO HELP DONALD TRUMP
DRAIN THE REGULATORY SWAMP."
KIM STRAWSER, A COLUMNIST FOR
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
HAS NOTED THAT THEN
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA'S EPA
CHIEF, LISA JACKSON, SPENT
NEARLY TWICE AS MUCH MONEY ON AN
OFFICIAL TRIP TO CHINA THEN WAS
SPENT ON A TRIP TO ITALY BY
PRUITT, WHO TOLD FOX HE
BELIEVES THE MEDIA LARGELY GAVE
OBAMA A PASS.
>> DO YOU THINK IF AN OBAMA
CABINET OFFICIAL RENTED AN
APARTMENT HERE FROM THE WIFE OF
A WASHINGTON LOBBYIST, YOU DON'T
THINK DONALD TRUMP --
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK ABOUT
IT?
THEY WEREN'T CARRYING ABOUT
THOSE ISSUES BACK THEN.
>> "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTING AT LEAST FIVE EPA
OFFICIALS WERE REASSIGNED, PLUS
THE FACT THAT PRUITT WANTED AN
EXPANDED 20% PROTECTIVE DETAIL,
VERY LARGE AND EXPENSIVE BUT HE
DID TELL ME IN THAT INTERVIEW
THAT BECAUSE OF HIS